good afternoon everyone i am priya
natarajan i'm a faculty member in the
departments of astronomy and physics at
yale and also the current director of
the frankie program in science and the
humanities
as you all know
we have been running this wonderful
inference
project talk series
and today we have convened uh for
the post talk discussion and
conversation
uh led by uh professor zena tavares
and
he will be
engaging with of course telling us a lot
about his own work and his perspective
and engaging with the most recent
colloquium that we had last week
given by
kyle cranmer
and kyle's talk was titled causality at
the intersection of simulation inference
science and learning
uh before i dive into telling you a
little bit more about zenna i would like
to start out by recognizing uh
mr and mrs richard and barbara frankie
for their generosity and their support
of this program and many other
interdisciplinary activities at yale
and just wanted to remind all of you in
the room that we are recording this
event and therefore all participants
will have their videos muted for the
duration of the talk
and as per usual questions may be
submitted at any time in the q a feature
and that we will uh get to them
so as you all saw last wednesday um kyle
gave us um
a wonderful overview of the role of
inference
in sort of model building be it uh
simulations
uh dealing with data large amounts of
data from for example the large hadron
collider and he showed us how we
actually do science and how we actually
learn um
by making uh causal inferences from
events that are detected for example
and so today we are
going to
hear a fresh perspective
from a slightly different disciplinary
vantage point which has been our um
goal with these uh talks and the
discussion series
so for for those of you uh who may not
yet have seen kyle's talk the recording
will be available shortly and let me
just
to inform uh where kyle was coming from
let me give you his brief biography so
he's currently a professor of physics
and data science at new york university
and visiting scientist at meta ai
in july he will be
become the director
for the american family insurance data
science institute at the university of
wisconsin uh madison
and so his work um
is really about frameworks that he's
developed for collaborative statistical
modeling
and was extensively used in the
discovery of the higgs boson in 2012
with the two separate uh experiments
that independently made this discovery
and he his current interests are sort of
at the intersection of physics
statistics and machine learning
okay um and for our speaker today uh
professor zenata virus xena tavares is
an associate research scientist in both
the data science institute and the
zuckerman mind brain behavior institute
he's the first joint hire between two
university level institutes at colombia
at columbia
in addition to his columbia affiliation
he's also the co-founder of basis
a new applied ai research non-profit
organization that aims to develop
universal reasoning systems and apply
them to help solve hard scientific and
societal problems
so it shows you the bent that zener has
in terms of application and domains of
application that do step out into
societal problems and so his research
aims to understand how humans reason
that is how they come to derive
knowledge from observing and interacting
with the world he also constructs
computational and statistical tools to
help advance his work on causal
reasoning probabilistic programming and
other related areas
prior to joining colombia he was at mit
where he received a phd in cognitive
science and statistics and was a
postdoctoral researcher in the computer
science artificial intelligence lab
season
xena's work has received
enormous recognition including an
international fulbright science and
technology award
and you know many other accolades for
his papers and his work
i'm not going to hold uh
take hog any more time and i would like
to invite zenna to please take the floor
and just want to say a thank you to both
of you uh for speaking to us today we
are absolutely delighted
thank you awesome thank you
so yeah so thanks for the introduction
yeah and i'm pretty excited to be here
and i'm looking forward to the
discussion
so let me just try to share my screen
great so so the title of my talk is
universal reasoning systems uh beyond
the frontier of simulation based
inference and so this is a
kind of a riff of of kyle's paper
fantastic paper which is the frontiers
of simulation based inference
and so the general theme of my talk is
going to be thinking about what is the
current status of
kind of simulation based inference and
what do i think is a few steps into the
future and how can we get that um but
this will be in the spirit of castle
very high level and hopefully pretty
short so we can spend most of the time
in the discussion
so as priya said kyle does hard and
difficult science you know investigating
the nature of the universe but my goals
are in comparison a little bit more
pedestrian a little bit more grounded uh
on earth and so i'm just interested in
like how can we build machines that can
reason a little bit better than the
current machines and in particular how
can you build machines that are somewhat
more human-like in their ability to
learn and reason about the world and so
here are just some kind of common sense
questions which a human might be able to
answer so looking at this picture you
might say well you know the driver's
drunkenness likely caused this crash or
you know if you had a weatherman give
you some report you might say well you
know that's implausible or if you're an
epidemiologist you might be
investigating some mutation and say well
you know this is really going to lead to
some large-scale societal
shutdowns or implications so how can we
build machines that can do this kind of
reasoning right now uh i believe there's
no machines that can really do this this
degree of disagree of general and
flexible inference and so that's kind of
my high level goal
so the basic foundation upon which i
work is the idea that humans
and you know presumably many other
animals too have mental models about how
the world works and so here in this
illustration the idea is that i as a
human has modeled about the outside
physical world and so i can you know
predict what's going to happen and and
this is a really powerful thing to be
able to do because it means that i can
imagine how the world is going to unfold
without the world actually unfolding
that in that particular way and that's a
very kind of life-preserving faculty to
have it doesn't necessarily need to be
about physical things in the world i can
also reason about other agents you know
think about what you're thinking you
know thinking about what i'm thinking
recursively you know up to some depth
and so there's a variety of different
kinds of phenomena in the world and the
basic premise of this approach is uh
humans they have mental models and they
use these models to imagine how the
world would unfold in various different
ways
and so my goal is to build universal
reasoning systems and we can get in the
discussion if
that's a meaningful concept
but i think there are basically three
fundamental pillars that we need to
think about at least three
one is the notion of knowledge
representations and again building
enough cars talk uh some of the most
exciting workers simulation based models
uh as a representation of knowledge the
second bit of is like different kinds
and modes of reasoning uh different
kinds of questions that we might be able
to ask
and the third is different algorithms
for inference and this is more the
computational perspective
and so what i want to do in this in this
brief talk is to look at these different
aspects and in each kind think about you
know one aspect of where we are right
now and another aspect of like where we
might be you know in the future
okay so
thinking about modes of reasoning and so
this is a slide from from carl's talk
and he points to kind of phase-based
inference uh as this principal
foundation and so what is the premise
behind bayesian inference well the basic
idea is that you have some
data you have some theory or some model
and given some uh and giving these two
pieces of information i can update using
bayes theorem uh to derive what should i
believe now conditional on the evidence
more generally i think of beijing
inference as a as a paradigm for logical
inference and so this idea has a long
kind of
philosophical foundation
but basically you have models you get
you introduce new data and you revise
your models based on evidence and so one
of the questions which i i want to get
into is like how general can we think
about this paradigm of blazing inference
currently the paradigms in which we do
based inference i'll argue are a lot
more constrained than the most general
paradigm and a lot large part of what i
want to do is think about what are the
ways in which we kind of what are the
ways in which we we are to extend the
notion of basic influence to account for
different kinds of knowledge and
different kinds of information about
how the world works and so let me just
give you an example of what i mean here
so another kind of inference
is is less of the of the kind that carl
spoke about last week and more of the
kind of logical reasoning that we do
every day
um and this could be you know individual
common sense reasoning all the way up to
kind of the scientific discoveries some
of the most some some of which are the
most important discoveries in in the
universe sorry
in the world to this point so let me
just give you an example so here's uh
galileo and i'm sure many of you know
galileo
and galileo is famous for for several
things but he's particularly famous for
discovering the nature of the moon and
so galileo you know
in the 16th century he looked up at the
moon and he came to this conclusion he
said the boundary which divides the part
in the shadow from the shiny part does
not extend continuously continuously in
an ellipse as would happen to be the
case if it was sorry the boundary which
divides the part in the shadow from the
shining part does not extend
continuously in an ellipse as would
happen in the case or a perfectly
spherical body but it but it is marked
out by an irregular uneven and very wavy
line so what galileo is saying here is
that if you look at the moon
as we will as we will do in the next
slide
you can see this wavy line between the
the light part and the dark part
and for what about this is an obvious
thing but at the time
people thought that the moon was perfect
sphere they thought it was his perfectly
spherical body but galileo looked up at
the moon and he said well it's not
but it wasn't sufficient for him to just
say it's not perfectly smooth he had to
convince his audience and so his
argument basically goes well if it was a
perfect sphere the line which connects
the light part to the dark part would be
a perfectly smooth ellipse but it's not
and therefore the moon is not perfectly
spherical
so this kind of argument which is almost
like a proof by contradiction if you if
you've done some mathematics
is very common in everyday everyday
reasoning
and it's a very important standard
reason because you know it led to a
revolution in how we think about the
world and so how can we build machines
that can do this kind of uh logical
reasoning
but at the same time it's not purely
logical reasoning because uh you know
one of the accents here is not very
clear is there some kind of formal
mathematical basis so it's this weird
kind of mixture between logical
reasoning and the messy real world
and so if you think about you know what
this looks like in a slightly more uh
formal sense we have some proposition s
which is that the moon is a perfect
sphere some proposition e that the
terminator which is the divider between
the light and the dark side is an
ellipse and then we construct this kind
of argument assuming that it's true uh
assume as is true as in assume that the
moon is a perfect sphere uh then the
terminator is ellipse it's also true but
it is not true and therefore our you
know our axiom is false
and so one of the things that we've been
looking at recently is can we build
machines that can do this kind of
reasoning with kind of real world data
and this is you know very much you know
uh just the idea stage and this is you
know in some sense i'm using this kind
of talk as an excuse to think about
things which are very speculative
but our goal is to construct something
like a proof tree so you may not be
familiar with this notation but this is
how people construct these formal
arguments in mathematics but instead of
a
uh a kind of a
normal mathematical logical proof
we combine that with a generative model
and so
on the one hand we have this formal
logical deductive tree on the other hand
all of the instances all of the elements
all of the kind of the variables which
constitute this logical tree are
themselves generative
by themselves variables in kind of the
kind of generative models that that kyle
spoke about last week
um and this is important because it's
not just sufficient to just you know
make this kind of logical argument i
have to connect it to all of that my
perceptual vision system i have i have
to actually look at the moon and infer
its shape i have to actually you know
use my visual system and so what we're
trying to do here in this very early
stage is try to bridge this gap between
logical deductive reasoning and kind of
the more general top generation
generative style kind of bayesian
influence that we're more familiar with
okay so i'm just going to move on
quickly so
going to algorithms for inference
so kyle had this uh
has a slide
uh and he and he's talking about you
know what is the kind of the state of
the art in
inference methods and i think i agree
with carl that one of the most exciting
areas here is
algorithms which combine neural
components with kind of old-fashioned uh
statistical components to get the best
of both worlds and in particular you can
have kind of neural models uh neural
surrogate models of of a kind of a hard
to compute uh
you know conventional model or you can
have a surrogate model of a summary
statistic
and this is really expanding and
exploding field of combinations of
neural models and kind of you know more
conventional statistical models
and just to go back a little bit one of
the kind of the key ideas behind this
approach which is in carl's paper is
the idea of automatic differentiation so
there's many kind of values in which you
would like to compute
uh in particular the kind of the
gradient uh
with respect to many different terms for
example the likelihood both in the
neural model or in a conventional model
but underlying all that is a technology
called automatic differentiation and
that's what allows you to get gradients
out of a very complicated model that you
can't do by hand
and so if you think about like what kind
of thing is automatic differentiation
well you know you can understand it from
the conventional calculus perspective
but from a programming language
perspective an automatic differentiation
is a program transformation that is it
takes your program the program that you
want to differentiate and it turns that
into a new program which gives you a
derivative or a gradient and your
ability to do that transformation relies
on
uh
having access to the model so it's not
just a black box model i can go in and i
can inspect the source code of the model
and be able to compute these derivatives
which i couldn't if it was just a black
box model
and so one of the things i i work on is
not automatic differentiation but a
different kind of program transformation
uh for a different need but all in
service of the same goal of uh kind of
inference and so what is inference in a
nutshell i think of inference as
generally an inverse problem i've got
some model it gives me some output and i
want to know what the input is or i want
to know what a distributional inputs are
um
but if that model is a program a
simulation program then
finding the
output that would give some you know
desired so finding the input that would
give some desired output it's really an
inversion problem i have to run the
program backwards
now you can do that in indirect ways but
one of my ideas was maybe we can tackle
this idea directly can we actually just
take the program and try to invert it
okay so what i mean by programming
version i mean take some program uh f
and its output is y i want to find x
such that y is equal to f of x
and so why do we want to do this
for for the reason that you know i just
described but in particular we can think
of these two examples so one is a
inverse graphic so i have let's say some
three-dimensional scene on the left and
i have some rendering function which
takes that scene and up as a
two-dimensional image and i want to go
backwards to find what is the
three-dimensional scene that created my
observed image
on the other hand i might have a control
problem right so i have a robot arm i
know where i want the hand to be what
are the joint angles which are going to
allow me to get my hand to that
particular point
so
as a software tool parametric conversion
take some programs so this is judeo code
you don't need to know the details but
the program is some function on the left
and we say well give me the inverse of
that program with respect to some uh
uh to some output right so i know what
the output of f is now give me some
input and so the goal is to build a
system which is pretty much as as
straightforward and simple as this and
it just outputs some some number 42. um
now how do we do this like so what is
the main issue so one issue is that most
things are not in vertical so how can we
uh have some notion of an inverse which
when our forward model is not invertible
um and so a simple example is just
addition if i know that f is equal to a
plus b and then and i know the output is
z how do i get uh you know the values of
a and values of a and b which would
output to to z
equal to five there's many combinations
it could be three and two four and one
and so on
and so one of the the approaches that
i've developed is called a parametric
inverse and so the basic idea is i'm
going to take my non-invertible function
and there's no inverse to that function
because it's not invertible and
construct this thing which we put a
parametric inverse and the basic idea
behind that is of all the different
combinations of x and y with sum to z i
want to parameterize that space of of
solutions so
uh i want to have a parametric
representation of all the different
combinations
and so let me just show you what that
means in the context of addition
um if
uh f takes as input x and y
uh then its inverse would take as input
the value uh that should be z sorry
and some parameter and it returns two
values one for x and one for y
such that if i add them together i get
back uh the output of the function
so this is a parametric representation
of the inverse of of of the simple
function addition okay so most of the
time we don't really care about just
addition we've got these really
complicated models that we want to
invert and just to kind of skip to skip
to the the point the idea is that this
composes so if i've got some complicated
program or some complicated procedure
for example i've got something which
takes in two numbers adds them together
and then squares them
i can take every element in that program
replace it with this parametric inverse
so replace addition with the inverse of
addition or the parametric inverse of
addition replace the square function as
the with the parametric inverse of the
square function and reverse the
direction of the order of the
computation and so the big kind of point
and the theorem is that this bottom
program is an inverse of the top program
and so what this means is that there's a
mechanical transformation i can take to
some model some simulation model and
literally transform the source code into
an inverse of that model now
you know
you should be skeptical because if that
were true then many many things would be
uh
uh you know which we know to be hard
would would be automatic right but the
basic premise holds and we can get into
some of the details of why that's
difficult in practice
um let's get over that okay so the last
kind of last area i want to talk about
is knowledge representations um
and so one of the key areas in which i
work is using programs to represent
knowledge like how do we uh
you know how do we represent knowledge
about the world i think programs are a
really good representation because
programs they have this compositional
structure you can include continuous
parts disk you know discrete parts uh
and simulation models are programs
neural networks and programs but more
generally the space of programs is a
very rich language
and in particular going back to my kind
of my galileo example if i think about
um you know different conceptions of the
universe how can we build a system that
could you know learn like a reason like
galileo or newton on someone right um
what are the what is the space that
represents all the different kinds of
theories that scientists have developed
over the world you know for example
newton's theory f equals m a or uh you
know copernicus had a model going back
further in time there's even older
models
this this structure which is able to
represent this you know this very rich
notion of of universe models doesn't
seem like it's a continuous vector space
it seems like it has a lot more
structure um
and so you know we haven't got quite
there yet but one of the you know the uh
the problems that we're working on is
this notion of program
program synthesis how do we learn a
program from data and so let me just
show you uh a quick example of that
okay so here is a here is a kind of an
ongoing project and this is done with um
surface background noise this is done
with josh tannenbaum and most of the
work is done by an undergraduate called
weird weirdest and the basic idea is
that we have this kind of this game like
environment on the right hand side and
this is a program on the left-hand side
and
i can interact with this hopefully um
let me just try to
okay so
okay so it's a little bit laggy but you
can see when i you know when i click you
know these kind of
these uh purple things come down but
even that is an inference right it could
just be a coincidence somehow it seems
to be the case that when i click that
causes this uh this purple thing to come
down
and if i press this blue thing and i
click you can see that something's
somewhat changed hopefully
maybe there's some bugs going on um
okay this is there's a side leg but you
can see this there's this kind of water
going down okay so the main point here
is that this this little world is not
particularly interesting it's actually
just models a water plug
but it's a very hard thing for
all of modern machine learning to to
learn because you've got these things
you know when i when i press this the
other thing nothing changes it's only
when i make this further action in the
world uh do i see the change do i see a
change in state so when i click now i
see these other pieces when i click this
black thing uh
things should disappear right um and so
what we're trying to do is is to build a
kind of a system and a paradigm of
learning where an agent will interact
with this kind of domain
and produce the entire source code on
the left-hand side right in other words
to learn the model of the dynamics just
from observing and interacting in the
world and this is a very hard problem
because it's not continuous it's a very
large
relatively speaking program uh it has a
distribution discrete structure uh and
if you've you know if you've thought
about this a little bit you can think
the space of prob the space of programs
of this length is enormous right and so
how can we figure out uh how to
synthesize this program from from data
and so in this example we can actually
do it and all of these examples we can
do it um
but this is part of discussion so i
learned there uh and but those are the
main kind of points that i i want to
focus on like knowledge representations
uh
uh algorithms for reasoning and modes
different modes of reasoning
uh thank you so much zenna for um sort
of charting out this landscape
uh before um having asking kyle to react
a little bit to um
the work that you presented
i'm just burning with curiosity given
your background in cognitive science
right as well so in terms of reasoning
are there sort of limits and capacities
that are actually hardwired or is this
not even a useful question i mean
i'd be happy to be told this abuse that
this is not a good question
yeah um
so so limits that are that are hard
white i think
i think the answer is i don't know i
don't think anybody knows uh it seems
like we've been able to figure out a lot
about the universe people like khan have
have helped us help help us do that from
really from really sparse
observations uh and so
i you know i would i would have to guess
that
um that there is a universality but it's
the reason which is bounded only by kind
of the physical constraints of
uh the world and and our ability to
compute right there's computation and
not so much by neurons and neural
structure and connections between
neurons okay
right great um so anyway kyle i turned
it over to you to um
begin um um your sort of engagement with
what uh zeno presented
sure yeah well i mean you know it's
always
you know i think uh
i i
you know
well not that we should look for
something to disagree on but we should
also not be boring and just uh you know
be like
because i think we we're exposed excited
about a lot of
the same things i i'm thinking back to
my talk i didn't really get to say too
much about some of this
uh this buzzword of uh you know
probabilistic programming which is very
related to what's uh but i i do think
that you know this idea that when you
have
some story for how the data came to be
which is you know as a physicist you
know if you're talking to another
physicist
you know it's a causal story it's very
natural you can you can take that story
and you can code it up into a computer
program so if you don't feel comfortable
thinking about computer programs i think
it's you're not going to really miss
anything if you just think of it as
the story about how the data came to be
and uh and what's nice is that you know
maybe you could come up with a computer
program that is very has a very
unnatural story but still produces the
same kinds of outputs but i think that's
not the spirit of the conversation the
spirit is much more that the computer
program is really just uh you know
capturing what what you think the actual
underlying you know
uh story is and
and there are so many different ways
that things could play out uh um and i
think it's really interesting when you
think about
statistical inference you know and
statistical models you know i introduce
the these terms of latent variables
which are uh you know random things that
happen in the process of generating the
data that you don't get to see
and uh
you know examples that i get sometimes
if you think about like the creation of
the solar system you know like you know
how did the moon happen well maybe some
big thing came and smashed into the
proto earth and you know knocked off a
big piece and there all these little you
know uh you know early on it was a disc
and things started to form i mean
there's some story that's going on and
and you could simulate that and it would
have all sorts of details about
individual rocks running into each other
and things like that we don't get to see
any of that and when you if you actually
wanted to simulate it you know it's just
enormously complicated uh like what
would be going on and especially when
you introduce
you know in the story of like rocks
coming you know you can imagine like did
this thing split into two pieces or
three pieces or did it just stay
together as one piece if you wanted to
follow that through the simulation you
get this just incredibly highly
structured
space of possibilities that doesn't look
like uh
you know it doesn't look like some uh
vector and you know like a a thousand
dimensional vector it's this very rich
and you know like graph structured thing
or something like that and you know so
much of statistics has not really
dealt with you know a lot of classical
statistics didn't deal with such
structured objects and i think one of
the things that's really interesting
right now is we're seeing this
this kind of you know it's partially
computing it's partially
you know it's hard to tell exactly
what's going on i think you know to some
extent i think what's significant about
machine learning
is that the ambition level has just
jumped so much like things that you
could have said but that you everyone
have laughed at you if you thought you
were going to actually like
you know
go after it like in some sense what you
were just describing your program and
version you know sure yeah you can do
that you could have said that like 10
years ago but everyone would be like but
that's never gonna work like that's why
would you try to do that but now
all of those things are on the table you
know and uh and and
and there are so many things that are
working
at a scale where
you know you wouldn't expect them to
that it's just kind of kind of it's it's
really refreshing because you're going
back kind of to really the first
principles
you know it's like instead of being
restricted by all sorts of you know
constraints that that you know that make
people kind of
have all these ad hoc workarounds people
are like kind of emboldened to go back
to like really first principle
approaches
and revisit them and and it's just
surprising that a lot of that stuff is
happening so to me i think you know the
idea that you're going back really to
like core bayesian inference kinds of
ideas but you're the types of models
that you're working with are just
so elaborately complicated and they map
so much more onto the way that we talk
about the world it's really exciting
um i don't know that's my first reaction
i guess
yeah i know i so
lots of things to think about and talk
about so
one of the one of the one of the phrases
that you haven't you had in your talk
last week was the idea that simulation
models
are causal models
right and
you know this is an intuitive thing to
to me uh and to many people part of
actually my phd work which i didn't
really focus on here is that taken
inside there literally and saying a lot
of the kind of the theory which theory
which has been developed in the context
of um kind of causal graphical models uh
can be extended to a richer class of
models in particular programs so
you don't you know the particular
formalism isn't that important actually
you can have a much richer formalism um
but there's this i think there's this
underlying question maybe to some degree
it's philosophical which is like
what is it that makes simulation models
uh causal are they necessarily are they
necessarily causal um
or you know can you think of simulation
models which aren't causal per se like
what is that
aren't they i mean uh just a quick
question
simulation models by construction causal
right
yeah
that's my question i mean i i i think it
is but i'm i'm kind of curious to i feel
like you start really getting into uh
lots of interesting subtleties is where
you start to dissect different notions
of causality uh and i kind of pointed at
two of them in my talk at the beginning
you know one is if you're if you have a
simulation
that's like a totally deterministic
evolution of you have some initial state
and and you just let it go you know um
okay it's causal in one sense but it's
also
not causal in the other especially if
it's time reversal
you know symmetric you know like the
arrow of time is confusing and and it's
all one object you know
uh you know it's all one thing you know
and so
you know when you think about like i
don't know space-time unfolding is it is
it evolving through time or is it just
one
object
of space-time that the whole future had
passed or all that you know so you get
but uh
but but
but then there's another sense you know
if you're if you're if your operational
definition of causality is that there's
some effective time ordering
and you have states and you know initial
you know one state goes to another state
goes to another state you know
simulations are almost by definition
causal in that way because they unfold
as the computation plays out right but
then you can have you know stochastic
components and all sorts of things
the other thing i think that's
interesting about having this
grounding a lot of the discussion about
causality in in this language
is that you some of the things that seem
you know can be confusing
they just uh
they they're revealed in a very precise
way so for instance
uh you know i could take you know if i
wanted to
you know in the language of like you
know you know pearl causality if i want
to intervene and go set some value to
something um like imagine i have a
particle and it has some it has some
energy and some momentum and some mass
like what if i just want to move its
energy well like that breaks some
condition that you know that this some
relationship that would normally be
there and that's like not an admissible
kind of intervention right and uh and
you know if you actually tried to do
this in code like
it's kind of weird depending on how you
wrote your code maybe it will continue
to proceed but you'll just get nonsense
out or maybe it will it will have a you
know segmentation fault because like at
some point
it it assumes that this condition is
satisfied you know
you know it's just kind of it lays bare
a few of the subtleties around
causality which i think often are
discussed and very like you know
not not there's anything wrong with
philosophy but in a philosophical
language where i think it it can be hard
to
to latch on to but there it can be kind
of grounded in a very concrete term
where you can uh separate out you know
slightly different
uh in a very yeah in a clear you know so
100 so
you know we have this paper and it's
called uh omega a language for counter
function reason and the point of this
paper is to to define what it means to
perform an intervention on a general
program
and one of the questions that arises is
exactly what you just said like what if
you do some intervention which breaks
the semantics of your program it makes
it invalid um like is there some is
there some scope in which you just say
well that's not allowed or or do you
just allow it and see what happens
and then the more you think about it the
more you
you get into this question of like what
is an intervention in the first place is
it just some arbitrary
you know
so in a common literature and
intervention is you know the
reassignment or some node to some new
value right um but when you go to more
expressive models that doesn't seem
deficient and so is there some like
underlying more fundamental logic which
is less tied to one particular
representation of a causal model which
would say this is a valid intervention
or not um right
and then going to your i guess your
point you made earlier if you think
about um
kind of these more abstract models so
like let's say i've got some low level
complex simulation
uh model uh like let's say physics
simulation but i want to be able to say
like some high-level intervention like
you know what if
i don't know like what if i through the
fall or something
right like
um how do those high-level interventions
interact with kind of the low-level
microscopic model i think is another
related question
yeah yeah um i pick up on a comment that
i see in the in the chat so jeremy
zucker said simulations don't need to
unfold in time one could specify
constraints among all the variables add
an objective and treat the entire
simulation as an optimization problem i
mean i i don't want to get into the
weeds too much i think that you know i
think the language that i
had used was that you know that
there's some some effective notion of
time meaning that like literally as the
computation evolves so like when you
compile the program and you run it like
it is there is a serial operation that's
happening so there's some effective
notion of time there that might not have
anything to do with like
time like as we think of it and you know
like on our watch or something um
and and that's kind of that example is
kind of interesting because i think and
i tried to sort of you know couch my my
statement earlier that you can have a
simulation that produces kind of the
right output but the the way that it
unfolds the story that it tells might
have nothing to do with how anyone
thinks the world works right so in that
sense it's totally anti-causal from like
a physical point of view you know it's
not like a plausible scenario for how it
actually came to be but as an
operational definition of what do i mean
by causal
like it you could use that like
you know
define it and like you know give it a
new name if you want you know
computational causality or something
like that you know it's some very well
defined notion of causality that uh that
that so even in that situation that
example you know if it's an optimization
problem like solving the optimization
problem would be like the causal model
for the data which is very unsatisfying
from the point of view of a physical
uh you know a story but made but totally
operationally well defined uh but it
also makes you think well actually well
maybe not you know maybe you know like
classical mechanics is expressed as a
you know can be expressed as uh euler
lagrange optimization problems you know
maybe somehow that's actually how the
universe
is implementing things you know who
knows right you know but i think that's
part of what's interesting about
describing it that way is that um
i don't know it allows you to ask some
pretty
uh
weird philosophical questions while
still grounding it in a very concrete uh
actionable
uh you know set of definitions you know
right and it seems like
it places the burden on the modeler
to
ensure that
you know the causality in the world that
they care about is mirrored in this
notion of computational causality
which you use to construct your model
which is
kind of a weird
but
maybe necessary
thing
right yeah or at least it's a route i
don't know you know necessary you know
but like it's a you know it's it's a way
to frame the discussion and also i think
that's what i meant when i say you have
to put it in by hand right that there's
a mapping that you do one use
yeah
and i made some references to this kind
of normative you know discussion and
things like that i think that's
what's a little bit interesting is if
you wanted them to talk about
causal inference from the point of view
of reasoning and you know our you know
you know there's a part which is
about it being
a useful thing to do that allows us to
learn efficiently from limited amounts
of data
right and so there the when you start to
frame it that way you can also it makes
it a little bit easier to talk about
you know sample complexity of learning
algorithms and these kinds of things and
and sometimes you can you can make some
pretty strong statements you know like
they're not just like the best algorithm
that i've thought of today i mean you
can kind of like show like there's no
way you're going to learn this without
like
exponentially more data than if you
thought about it in a different a
different way right you know so
um
and i think those are those are relevant
uh
you know i i think that that
that complex those complexity issues i
don't think are
just like oh a matter of computation
they're not like fundamental i think
those things you usually are probably
something
strong signs of something that's
actually much more fundamental you know
so and i do have a question for zuna i
guess it's like the um
so you you talked about kind of uh this
inverting the
the programs and things like and i think
i think that's super cool and i think
yeah this whole
you know like what that example
probabilistic programming automatic
differentiation many other
there are things that are this kind of
high level program transformation or
really interesting
set of ideas to think about um
what i'm but you also gave this example
about you know the argument that the the
moon is not perfectly smooth where it's
super very fast and loose type of
argument and and and you know when i
think about
i don't know like you know how i think
about like what's going on say at the
lhc when something strange is happening
in the data and i want to try to figure
it out um you know it's definitely in
the fast and loose category i'm not like
iteratively uh inverting my my mental
model for like how the low-level
you know particle interactions happened
or something um so i'm curious since
this is squarely
i just want a little bit of a
clarification so what do you mean by
fast and loose are you talking about
eliminative reasoning or um
oh well this example about are arguing
that the uh you know the the
the the terminator of the moon is wiggly
you know it had a a logical
element but at the same time it's sort
of based on you know there's an
observational component and it's not
really
uh
well i don't know i mean i guess a lot
of other maybe other examples of human
reasoning like that were given at the
beginning like the the the uh
the the car accident and the you know
the weather and stuff like that it's not
you know i don't think well i don't know
i i don't feel like humans are doing
some kind of uh
logical reasoning at that level as kind
of uh you know some approximate i mean
they're they're manipulating high-level
sense of reasoning in that way but it's
not it's not so formal and once you get
into something that's more complicated
where that you get this explosion of
of of possible paths you know the
inverse of that problem is you know has
an explosion of possibilities i don't
feel like we're like keeping track of
all the possibilities but some somehow
we have some effective way of
filtering
yeah of kind of playing out entire like
not individual scenarios but like whole
classes of scenarios that kind of are
placeholders for
distributions of possibilities and we
manipulate them just very efficiently
and we we were able to like pick the
right abstraction to do that and to me
that's uh
it's it's magic i don't know like
yeah i mean i wonder if that's because
we have some kind of
mechanism to eliminate possibilities
right so that the
or we reduce the complexity basically as
you're saying right somehow
we are able to reduce the complexity of
possibilities um
in human reasoning
yeah
so why did you have a specific question
or just just create i mean i just think
i just i just felt like the two
different things were and the two things
you showed were in some sense
you know they have the same underlying
uh uh drive to them but they're kind of
opposite extremes like one is a very uh
you know like you're making this
reasoning
i don't think people are going through
all these possibilities and the other
example was this kind of a program
uh you know a transformation which is
going to have this explosion of of
possibilities right and so
right right yeah so i think you know
thinking about um what i call this kind
of you know proxima logical reasoning or
you know it's not it's not quite
formalized yeah i think that the goal
there is to is to characterize what i
think we would you know we do all the
time right so maybe if you
i don't know if you
went home and the window was open you
might be like well you know my partner
must be here otherwise it wouldn't be
open right and so we do this kind of
thing all the time so when you when you
come to that conclusion are you doing
like a massive simulation of all the
possible ways right um but it's but it's
not i don't think it's just about
efficiency it's a it's a different form
of reasoning in the same way that
producing a mathematical proof is
different from sampling right it's not
just like a different kind of algorithm
it's a different nature right yeah
mathematical proof has this kind of
logical deductive structure right this
tree structure which can be formalized
in many different ways
but i don't think
that has been
kind of adapted
to
you know common sense scenarios and so
part of what i want to do to try to do
is think about like what is that because
it seems like pretty fundamental like
way prior to galileo
uh there were many people who came to
the conclusion that the moon was
mountainous you know through this kind
of
you know logical informal deductive
reasoning uh back to you know that back
to aristotle's days um
and so it seems to allow us to come to
insights way beyond our observational uh
kind of capacity um but it's you know i
you know what it is i don't know but i
just feel like there's a whole and part
of what i'm trying to convey here is
that
aside from the current paradigms of
reason and inference uh which parametric
inversion is part of this kind of the
second the second thing
i think there's just many more
interesting modes of reasoning so to
give you another example um
one thing i think about a lot is this
notion of actual causality so going back
a little bit to this notion of causality
simple question right did a cause be for
example like did i you know i threw a i
threw a rock it hit a window and it
smashed um did my phone on the rock
cause it went into smash right it sounds
it sounds quite simple and you know how
can you make a machine
do that kind of reason and it turns out
that it's incredibly hard right it seems
simple like you might say well like had
i not thrown then the window wouldn't
have smashed that sounds like a
reasonable thing but it turns out that
breaks down in many different ways
because like what if something something
else would have caused it to to crash
any to crash anyway and so
um this is a basic question
which we don't have the definitions
right about i mean let alone the
algorithm don't have the right
definitions and what it points to the
more i think about this is like this
notion of causality uh
as almost like a epistemic question like
when i think about causality is it
really about you know the underlying
world or is it more just about human
minds right like you know not is it
causality about the world or is it part
of our mind
and so is our hope to get these kind of
pristine notions of causality a fool's
errand because fundamentally they're
kind of messy concepts or is it more
this kind of metaphysical thing which
you know a little bit like probability
where there is this underlying pristine
theory we just have to discover it um
but we haven't we haven't got that yet
so maybe that's a little bit abstract
but that's that's kind of how i how i've
been thinking about it recently
yeah and i think it's interesting i mean
definitely this uh
yeah i mean the
well what to say i mean it goes back a
little bit to
i mean this idea that you're trying to
come up with like plausible explanations
for something right i think points a lot
to this idea that you have uh
you know you don't it's not that you're
just running some program that was
already written for you you're you're
kind of constructing the the program as
you go like you know could this have
been the explanation and if if so then
you can kind of mentally simulate what
would happen and the consequences of
that thing um but to do so you know you
you kind of have a vocabulary of
different ontology of different kinds of
things and how they can how you can
compose them
and uh and you know a lot of programs
are kind of they're just
more rigid versions of the same thing
where the the types of stories you know
it's sort of a choose your own adventure
but it's very
very structured here you kind of like on
the fly i get to uh add things
and i think you know that
in my talk i mentioned a little bit
about
hypothesis generation and stuff i was
trying to you know contrast against
if you just think about like a lot of
kind of black box machine learning
algorithms that maybe can solve like the
particular scientific tasks that you're
on right now better than anything else
on the market that's maybe that's true
but like what do you do next right you
know like if you uh you know you test
that particular theory at high accuracy
and you get the most out of your data
and that's great but like now now what
experiments should you do right like if
you if you somehow can't introspect like
if or something goes wrong like the data
does not look like you expected from
your theory
like what what what do you do you know
and and the and uh you know in in the
human way of doing it even though maybe
it's not squeezing everything out of the
data like it it has this explainability
component to it because the way the data
is being analyzed is composed of a bunch
of things that you you understand and
then you can go inspect it every little
step of the way and if anywhere in there
you can isolate where things went wrong
or were unexpected and then that
motivates
generating new hypotheses which are news
stories that might explain why it went
differently and i i think that's
absolutely key to how
science as i
know it and people that i know that they
do it you know how they would approach
such a problem you know and uh and so
and what's good is that you know yeah
sure it looks different than kind of the
current uh ai but it's actually it's
adjacent to stuff that's happening i
mean you're doing it i'm doing some
stuff so it's not like some radical like
oh we're on the wrong path it's it's
like right now
we're figuring out how to do these
hybrids between
you know probabilistic programming that
have you know take advantage of the the
powerful parts of current deep learning
things and you know mix all this stuff
together so i you know there are a lot
of people that are
that say oh we're on the wrong path or
whatever but i feel like actually
they're these are starting to come
together in a way that looks uh very
exciting and uh i think
yeah i know yeah and one of the things
that i think is interesting and i think
it was in one of your charts to some
degree right is
this this notion that um the scientific
process is a lot more
expansive than
you know often the kind of the more
narrow view that we we give it you know
in other in other words like you know if
you if your experiment didn't work or
you got some strange observations uh
you might invent a new an entirely new
theory you might invent a new form of
mathematics right um it's not just uh
you know like a constrained action space
you can really
change and
the fundamentals at least like
historically humans have like you're
building upon this like massive
foundation and so
i'm really interested in like how do we
like all of these things that we take
for granted when you know by the time we
bought a modern machine learning tool
we've already taken for granted calculus
and you know uh what are the objects
that we care about all of that is kind
of given by the humans but if we want to
build machines that can do that part of
the process too
what do we have to what do we have to
give them um one one question i wanted
to ask was uh around this you know this
notion of like modeling and
representations of knowledge you have
the term this term collaborative
modeling which i think is great i wish i
invented it but i certainly steal it
um
what do you think are the kind of the
key components of
of of building a collaborative
model at scale like how you know how i
i'm very curious like your
interpretation of this phrase but i'm
particularly curious like what are the
kind of the barriers which prevent like
me as let's say an epidemiologist and
somebody else says i don't know like a
climate scientist from kind of getting
together and building some model which
takes into account all these different
components in some coherent and cohesive
way
yeah well that yeah that's it
that's a great um i like how you threw
it back at me
yeah
well i think you know there's a part
which
you know when when when i first like you
know coined that term uh i
it was it was applied to a pretty narrow
uh set of problems which was really kind
of
uh you know how do you do statistical
modeling kind of really in the context
of sort of uh
you know like lhc where there's lots of
different you know lots of different
data sources or views of a larger data
set uh you know that things are related
in various ways you want to
previously it was very top-down and
rigid sort of structured to be able to
bring those things together and it
didn't scale well and then at some point
we've figured out a way like uh to be
able to let people kind of uh work in a
more decoupled way
understand their part of the problem let
their you know be the experts and and
their problem figure out how they want
to think about it and parameterize it
but still maintaining the ability to
bring them all together and kind of co
and do some coherent inference in the
end and that was like uh and once we
introduced there's just some underlying
technology really that you know kind of
in terms of
you know model sharing and you know
interfaces and things like that and once
we got that part right there was just
then this like literally exponential
explosion of complexity uh which was it
was amazing to watch and it was kind of
scary also because like uh you know
computationally everything became very
hard very quickly and so we had to
figure out how to keep up but um
but what i do think is kind of
interesting and it's a little bit more
on the meta side is that in this
you know
when we when we went to you know started
working on these like simulation-based
inference problems what i love about
that is that it's really like a lingua
franca for
methodological experts and domain
experts to be able to really effectively
collaborate because there's somehow you
you encapsulate a lot of details about
your problem and you expose some way of
talking about it like but literally
through interfaces that methodological
people can work with where you know if
they don't need to know the details they
can kind of be you know shielded from it
uh but but it it but you're not like uh
you're not
you're not losing a lot of the the
real uh complexity that's going on
inside there and i think that
you know that it's just you know true
that we i'm now able to have
conversations with neuroscientists and
and you know cosmologists and
epidemiologists and you know
phylogeneticists and stuff at a level
that i've never been able to have before
and and so and and then and actually
it's also been a way for me to
understand their problem much more
efficiently like even the details of
their problem because like the on you
know the onboarding of that is really
useful but there's a part which is uh
you know it's really you know actually
much more on like software engineering
interface level which allows you to
actually build models and do composition
compositionality like you would want
uh that but it's very actionable in that
sense but it also kind of
pays off in a way that you would hope
you know a bigger a bigger uh kind of
you know more ambitious answer to your
question that that's something that
sounds like as lowly as like you know
good interfaces or something but uh it
actually i think sort of starts to
realize that and and it's really
compelling idea because
you know if you think about covid
simulations like you know our
epidemiologists you know the simplest
ones or you just have a some uniform
population that doesn't even necessarily
exist spatially it's just like there's
some number of people some number of
people have it there's some chance that
you know they're going to give them
and then you get these like differential
equations but those differential
equations are really like all averages
of something they're not they don't look
like have some underlying stochasticity
and they don't like now let's say i want
to actually think of it as actual people
and they're actually live in actual
cities and i know where they are like
and i mean it you know can
you know it can be scary sounding but i
mean if you just in terms of the
richness of the model like you know you
can you can just you can well this you
know this you know group of people in
this neighborhood behave a little bit
differently you know you got like the
20-somethings over here and they've got
the you know
other people over here they have
different patterns they interact
differently with each other you know um
and and you can definitely see the story
about how you would actually build up
such a model where people that know
about the different pieces contribute in
some much more collaborative way and
that's like you know that's exciting um
i mean you have to be careful
but i mean yeah i think like as i
thought about this more like it seems
like one key thing is as you just said
like how do you have these
entities who are which are shared
between different groups so one model is
talking about people or populations of
people the other model is talking about
people at a more fine-grained level but
as humans we just got to communicate and
say yeah those you know that's about
people or maybe we use a variable name
to indicate that that's a person right
but it seems like a lot of the knowledge
that we have in our
about the world is not it's not actually
in the model representation it remains
in our heads and then we communicate
with each other to tell us you know what
that means right but it seems like if
you want to be able to build you know
systems that can uh really reason
they're going to have to in some sense
represent the entire stack so all the
way down you know it's not just like a
an abstract variable but this really
represents
a human in some sense
it's a lot of implicit knowledge
that is brought to bear
right right
and then the second thing is like if you
have different people contributing
different models which may be
inconsistent right you may you need some
way to integrate that you know that
knowledge together right and yeah
is there a kind of a sound way to do
that or is it more like a heuristic
approach but i mean there may be
instances where you not only need to
integrate but you may need to arbitrate
right between
two
um
yeah
um
i was just looking at the the questions
but uh yeah i know i think it's uh well
the last thing i mean
i just
tag on that you know this whole story
also is is a is a natural path to being
able to uh try to do the thing where you
have the different hierarchies of
representations you know uh you know if
you can figure out some way of having
this kind of ontology and almost like a
type system over the different kinds of
entities you know you can certainly
start to make things
that are uh you know
hierarchical or some many diminished or
like you know here's an alternate way of
thinking about the the problem with a
totally different set of things you know
um and they
you may just switch from one modeling
paradigm to another modeling paradigm
you might not be able to mix them but
for one task one is appropriate and the
other ones the other ones appropriate or
you know who knows
or be able to telescope in and out uh
and refine the detail if you need it and
if not you know
enjoy the the benefits of
of you know working at a high level um
but yeah if you have inconsistencies and
stuff i think you know that's the
you know i think that's uh
which is certainly real i i don't i'm
guessing things get
you know a little bit messy at that
point you know
it goes to somewhat deeper point so go
into the example you had in your talk
with the
the machine the kind of the bean machine
where you had right you know it produced
this like you know non-conventional
distribution um and as you said like
it's a
determination process but you can think
of it stochastically um
and so i guess the question is like
uh
you know i'm i'm kind of coming from the
more subjective bayesian perspective
which is that when i think of that as a
distribution that's more like you know
my my kind of belief
right about it about its outcome um and
so when we go to languages or
representations for for probabilistic
knowledge
there's a kind of a subject there's like
a hidden subject right you know if i say
x is some normal distribution maybe
there's like a hidden extension to that
phrase which is like x is a normal
distribution believed by me
and so
if we want to integrate lots of
different knowledge from lots of
different sources maybe we need an
explicit representation of
where the kind of the province or the
sources of these beliefs so that if you
know x is a normal belief by a person x
and y is a you know x is a you know i
don't know a beta distribution believed
by person y
there's some way which we can take kind
of the relative relative like credences
of these two individuals to say well
okay right uh i'm gonna you know
integrate that in some consistently so
maybe that's a long way of saying that
maybe
an integral part of of uh kind of a
sound way to integrate knowledge is to
make explicit the notion of subjectivity
you know in our probabilistic models i
think yeah that's the kind of yeah no i
think you know i mean i i alluded
briefly to uh that in particle physics
it's one of the kind of last holdouts
where uh you know bayesian inference is
not fully embraced but right it's
partially because uh when you start
talking about things like the prior
distribution on some fundamental
constant of nature or like does this
fundamental particle exist or not or
does this symmetry of nature exist you
know is that does nature have that
symmetry or not like um you can't base
it on data so you really have to embrace
the subjective version of that but there
is not an agreement among
physicists right if there was like some
you know wide agreement then maybe no
one would care but if when you have
wildly different subjective
priors associated to different scenarios
like what do you do
operationally right you know it's it's
tricky um i think that
it well that you know this would be an
entire other hour discussion but i think
there's a part which is maybe worth
saying is that
oftentimes we
couch a lot of this and uh and like
bayesian inference and a lot of these
things is somehow like
there's like a rational or optimal way
of doing it and and that like the sound
way kind of presumes that like we should
be trying to do something that's like
consistent or whatever
there's another view which is that uh
that you know we're not really
optimizing anything we're not like you
know we just we're just doing
and there's like there's kind of
dynamics you know uh and especially when
you think about like a you know a very
heterogeneous group of people that have
heterogeneous access to different pieces
of information and then you just think
about behavior
uh you know it's not necessarily uh
you know maybe in some cases it's well
modeled by something that looks like
some bayes optimal something but in many
other cases maybe it's just like i was
hungry and that's why i didn't
you know
and uh and so then you get into a
question what are you what exactly are
you trying to describe are you trying to
are you trying to be descriptive or
prescriptive in the whole story you know
so um zena there's a question for you in
the chat
if everything in the ontology stack
should be up for evolution can anything
pristine at all as in your
characterization of probability theory
remain
and to kyle can your statement that the
particle physics simulators already
express a wide variety of alternative
theories be taken literally enough to
mine it for grammars of nearby theory
space i guess the expansion of uh
permitted theories interesting question
do you wanna have a go first yeah
i'm just trying i'm trying to interpret
it um
so
i think i would like some clarification
but maybe i'll make a guess uh exactly
what you enjoy on
um
yeah i was going to say boyan could you
clarify um and type in the q a
i guess really what do you mean by
evolution there
i can uh respond to the other part if if
you want uh to have time um
or maybe he wants to hear the answer and
that's not fair
go ahead yeah i i guess i'd say that you
know i had made the comments you know
last week that
you know there's a part where
uh when you're doing simulation based
inference it seems like well how do you
learn anything new because you already
have it in your simulator uh and
and that seems
reasonable and i tried to re reframe
that is that like whenever you're doing
inference uh it's kind of in the context
of some model right so like if the to
the extent that an inference looks like
this inverse problem it's an inverse of
something and so like that there's a
model there kind of uh you know to start
the discussion so the um so in the case
of particle physics the model is not uh
like the standard model of particle
physics which is a specific theory
uh is is like one point in the space of
possible theories that can all be
expressed
in the language of whatever quantum
field theory and so and so that language
of quantum field theory allows you to
express all sorts of other uh you know
possible scenarios and universes that
can be described for the most part you
know
i think most professional physicists
feel like essentially anything that
looks remotely like the you know is
anything like our universe is going to
be expressed in in that language so so
in that sense it's very it's a very
expressive one and if you wanted to work
outside of that language
you know uh
you you really everything starts to kind
of
like you really have to revisit
everything you know and and yeah and so
um so in terms of mining mining it for
the grammar of nearby theory space i
mean in some sense it depends a little
bit on how you mean it but i think
in many senses absolutely yes and
there's a very
systematic approach for kind of how to
you know like if you go to some theory
how to expand around it in a nice way
and to the the grammar is like really
very explicit and that's one of the
things uh
actually another one of josh tenenbaum's
former students brendan lake who's here
at nyu uh uh he and i have had various
discussions about uh
you know this kind of can we
operationalize like rediscovering the
standard model uh where but where you
operate in this kind of grammar of
theories that's restricted and quantum
field theory and uh it would be
computationally expensive but i think
you you absolutely could and and the
part that's a little on one side it
sounds super ambitious on another side
it's it's kind of so clear how you would
go about doing it that it almost is like
is it worth the worth of effort you know
like it would
so it would be great to do it and to say
like here's an automated algorithm that
like basically went through the space of
theories in some
you know uh structured way and basically
came upon the standard model and said
this is it and i don't have any you know
evidence for anything beyond it
um and it would be fun to do um i think
it's kind of in another sense it's kind
of clear how you would proceed um
so zenna there's a bit of a
clarification from boyan
yeah
yeah did you see that yeah yeah so yeah
i think i have a better sense of this
question so going back to what you're
talking about earlier
[Music]
which is that scientists changed the the
foundations both the mathematical
foundations and the ontologies which we
use uh in various different ways and uh
so i think boyer's question is if you
permit that then you know how do you
prevent your kind of your house from
just like crumbling on how do you
uh
you know it seems like if there's no
kind of
stable foundation then anything goes
maybe that's my interpretation of this
question and
the answer yeah i don't know um
i i think maybe when we think about a
theoretical framework maybe you think
thinking about it less as being like
true or not true is it's more useful or
not or not useful um
and
and i think if we maybe going
a little bit to what you said earlier
kyle um
like you know what is our if we have
some kind of
goal which may be to predict the future
which may be to
uh you know make valid inferences we can
think about all the layers below as like
you know either in service of that or or
not and so i think provided that there
is some kind of foundational uh not
foundation there is some kind of
external objective i think we can be
flexible with these foundations uh as
long as they're in service and to your
kind of example like property theory as
pristine
um
no i think it's a pristine model of like
rational thought
uh which is really dependent on you know
agents like i think it would be hard
maybe you know maybe maybe this is where
carl might disagree
but i think it might be hard to um
uh kind of justify probability theory as
being like uniquely good in the absence
of
of rational agents um
but that is kind of maybe a
controversial claim but yeah i'll leave
it there
and i guess there's another question
about
counterfactuals i guess the references
to
you know there was this book by um and
this work by david deutsch and kiara
marletto
the science of can and can't i remember
reading that a physicist journey through
the land of counterfactuals
i think the question here is you know
counterfactuals can serve as an
important thinking tool right in the
deeper exploration of causal connections
and alternate scenarios
and so the question is um
that you know
they argue that describing physical laws
in terms of counterfactual tasks they
generate and they counter possible tasks
that cannot be generated
and the question is is this kind of
reasoning seems very similar to the way
that galileo was able to infer the
non-smoothness of the lunar surface
right
yeah there is something very
counterfactual about it right is this
um this kind of you know if this were
true right the moment you have a wood in
your sentence you're kind of in this
control actual yeah anti-factory regime
and so it does seem that this kind of
reason both touches on kind of actually
reason and also this kind of
proof by contradiction star reason maybe
those two things are equivalent in some
fundamental way i'm
kind of i'm not i'm not certain yet um
but i i
yeah i think it's interesting again
going back to this earlier question of
like what like what is the status of
these kinds of
statements right if i make a counter
factual statement is that a is that
something that's true or false or is it
just yeah i was just gonna say it's one
festival right i mean i'm kind of
uncomfortable in a way i mean they're
tricky counterfactuals are quite tricky
right because they're not testable
and so what is that for example in
science i've never quite understood
what sort of their utility is um
festival right
i guess i guess what you know what
lies at the foundation of a valid
counterfactual i think is the validity
of your model in the world right if you
have a correct model then in some sense
your counterfactuals are correct by
by construction and so even though
they're not testable there might be a
you know a sense in which they can be
correct or not correct which gets pushed
down to the question of is your model
correct or not correct but that becomes
complicated because you know right
yeah so i mean i was thinking of you
know the kinds of examples they use
right i mean i remember one i think
there's something like you know the
possibility of building a steam engine
which existed long before
the first one was actually built
is something they give as an example of
a counterfactual right and i mean so and
this is so as it exists in the domain of
the possible and its functioning does
not violate the principle of
conservation of energy
and whereas the sort of counterfactual
property imposed by the laws of physics
that you know um
is that you cannot for example build a
perpetual motion machine right i mean so
these are the sort of ways in which um
they use it so i mean it's a way to
permit ourselves to sort of entertain
the idea of possible ones right right
right or alternate universes that are
like variants of our current realities i
mean that's where i get stuck and say
well you know it's not testable so um
right i saw an article recently which
was trying it's like a
logical philosophical article trying to
give a formal definition of what a law
is you know right
and the way they're trying to do it is
say well it kind of must remain true
under
any counterfactual scenario right so
there's a difference between saying you
know i haven't done this yet versus this
is impossible which is quite a hard
distinction
yeah
anyway i don't know how do you have
thoughts amazing
one of them is that yeah i think that on
the counter factual
it makes sense you know when coupled
with a model because like then you can
basically
with that model you can sort of simulate
you know other scenarios right and so
it's not testable in the sense that you
can't like literally with that you know
go back and change the thing that that
happened a different way so for that
particular instance yes it's not
testable but
it's testable within them within the
model and it has consequences you know
and so like you know like so then you so
then you if you think of it in more of a
decision theory way like you're going to
you use your model answer you know ask
the question what if i had done blah
blah blah you know simulate or something
reach some conclusion and based on that
you're now going to take some informed
action in the future you know if your
model is bad then you you may end up you
know walking off your cliff or doing
something bad you know if if your model
is good then it may help guide you to
you know
yeah so in that sense it it has
consequences
but it's maybe not testable in a very
you know strict way also if you think
you can somehow like
re-prepare an equivalent state or
something like that and then sort of do
it again and you have some notion of
exchangeability
then
it sounds like if you are able to
simulate it then it's testable in that
way right in the way that simulations
allow you to
yeah and then you know but the other
example where you know if you can
somehow re-prepare the a similar initial
state and do it again with the with the
you know with the opposite you know with
a different uh the counterfactual
scenario um you know then it uh you know
that's effectively simulating you're
just using actual the actual world to do
the simulations so you know uh
but but it still involves a model in the
sense that uh
you're saying a lot when you say that i
think this initial state is is the same
as the the previous initial state right
um you know like how do you know that
that's true right you know that's
effectively a model in the sense that
you think that whatever you did to
prepare this initial state is like
equivalent um and then you know so you
yeah sorry
but but in both cases whether it's
simulated or it's like uh actually like
in a lab and and you know doing
something uh you're still bringing some
assumptions to the table and and uh and
and you look to see what happens you
reach some conclusion and then you you
you act accordingly and and if you're
wrong you know if the if your your
process of preparing the same initial
state actually didn't take into account
like the temperature in the room and
that's important then you will reach the
wrong conclusion and your car is not
going to work i guess a lot of my
skepticism of counterfactuals really i
have to confess right comes out of a
bias
is that this this relates you know this
is sort of an offshoot of this idea of
multiverses that people are constantly
playing with you know this idea that the
multiverse you know there's an infinite
number of possible universes
and you know it has obviously broad
explanatory scope so it's kind of
attractive
and but nothing you know about the
multiverse is really testable right so i
think that is where i um that's where my
sort of uh notion that you know this is
not so um testable right
is that you know
we've had a multiverse talk in the
series
right yeah
so i mean i i you know and i always get
stuck right when we think of when i try
to put the kinds of conceptual things
that you both talked about and in sort
of the multiverse frame right so you
know if the universe in principle you
can imagine universes for which you know
the newton's law of gravitation takes on
a completely different form from ours
right
and or you know multiverse in which
gravity may not even exist right so how
would you discriminate between those
universes where newton's law merely
takes a different form but one in which
you know gravity at all doesn't exist
therefore that law doesn't exist
anyway so i think i'm um
it's uh it's a different rabbit hole
that we don't um
uh we don't want to go down and uh
there's a question that uh somebody has
asked uh zena for that um do you have a
reference for the article that you just
mentioned about the discussion of laws
like what the relationship between a law
and the counterfactual that
um it
all is valid
if you email me i can find it
somewhere in my internet history um i do
have another question if you have time
still for yeah of course yes yeah please
yeah yeah
so um
this notion of like abstraction or
different models at different levels of
fidelity has has come a few different
times um
and
uh and i think as maybe you indicated
this also into it seems integrated into
this other question of like how do you
have different how do you do this kind
of collaborative collaborative modeling
so an example that i used to say when
obama was president i said like you know
suppose somebody asked me um i suppose i
asked you like how tall is malia obama
um this is a kind of a very common not
common question but a very ordinary
question right and so most people don't
know the answer but they can make a
guess right they can say well
you know maybe you know her her father
was a president and presidents are kind
of typically tall uh so maybe she's
little or you know or i know she's a
woman maybe she's and so all these
different kind of sources of information
um maybe you know her ethnic background
that will come to integrate into uh your
your conclusion um and so going to my
question
when i think about how do we build
um
kind of very large
uh collaborative models
uh i can think of almost like a a
multiverse
of of different models that are that are
connected together it seems that one
integral part must be
uh the notion of different models being
more or less abstract than another to
give another example when i think about
something as simple as a night switch
right if i i understand the light switch
as just you know some binary model press
the light switch the light comes on
another level you know i studied
electronic engineering as an
undergraduate i understand the electric
circuitry behind it at another level i'm
just a human so i understand the
physical you know the physical actual
geometry of a light switch i have all of
these different forms of knowledge and
they all influence how i interact with
the light so if it doesn't work right my
light switch doesn't turn on it could be
because the electronics are broken it
could be because the london power
station is down it could be because the
the mechanical switches is broken and
i'll choose the right level uh
appropriately uh or at least i'll try to
um and so go into your simulation based
models and simulation based inference
do you have an intuition about how we
can build
representations of models which
can capture
these different levels of abstraction
all these different perspectives or
different different sources of knowledge
in a way again which is coherent and is
that a different question to this
collaborative
uh question
but yeah
i mean that's a topic that i'm very
interested in and sort of
wanting to to work while i'm working on
but in in various levels so i mean part
of it is i think you know
also just asking some easier questions
at first which
with that those kinds of questions as a
goal but uh you you even get into the
situation of you know say that you
already are kind of handed uh the
different you know models at different
abstraction levels and and also you
probably want to prepare for the fact
that the ones that are like a higher
level of abstraction maybe are not quite
as accurate right so so you know how do
you incorporate the fact that uh that
the
the
you know the fidelity of the model in
terms of how well it describes the data
and and and how would you use it right
like say you have those models
how are you going to use it so i think
about things kind of in a sort of
reinforcement learning or
decision making
kind of scenario which is you know if
i'm going to use this for planning you
know like one way of thinking about
world models that makes them very
concrete is when you think about using
them for planning or or decision making
right and so
um that helps ground the thinking a
little bit which is
yeah you know how you know
uh
you know if you did have them and you
know that the different levels of
accuracy and different like trade-offs
in terms of how expensive they are to
run you know what would you do and
that's not quite answering that you're
you're the the deeper question which is
like how do you come up with them in the
first place but i think it's probably
something to think about at the
beginning because it's going to guide a
lot of the
the way that you organize it and think
about things you know um
um but it's it's it's very interesting
and i mean the other well we have you
know
doing some exploratory thing right now
which is like kind of uh
you know uh hopping between you know you
know these like game of life type
cellular automata things you know you
have some very low level
you know model that describes kind of
how things evolve uh but sometimes you
get these sort of emerging phenomena
that look like little organisms that
walk and you know they can run into each
other and collide or do something you
know and uh if you wanted to
try to figure out uh
you know how
you know the long time behavior of one
of these things like and then maybe
you know and there might be interactions
like if you know that you make a little
walker and it's moving along like at
some point you don't need to resolve all
these details you just just
zoom along until it looks like they're
going to collide right but there's this
interesting part where you kind of hop
up and down between like once they go
collide then you need to drop into the
low-level picture that's like exactly
how are they hitting and you know model
that and then uh so that that ability
like the fact that we're even having
this conversation right
like i just in very few words explained
something that's in my mind and you know
the
you know you kind of know what i'm
saying maybe you know i don't know like
but this jumping back and forth between
the levels
it's it's it's uh
right right so
it seems very important to me it seems
very very important and uh
and uh and how you do that is a good
question so i think you know one part is
just to give it start with them and then
see how you use them and then maybe that
gives them some guidance
yeah i guess like another example i
think of is you know suppose i go to
work and i i
put in my bag
a flask or a water bottle i don't need
to reason about all the fluid dynamics
of
you know the the water inside the bottle
as i was able to work but when i get out
and i need to actually pour the water
into the glass now i do need to actually
reason right it's kind of low level
dynamics and so it seems like this
flexible
ability to jump between
different representations or different
levels of fidelity
seems key and prior to that it's just
like how do we even represent these
different
levels in
a coherent structure
yeah
but also i mean isn't this also
something obsessed something about the
task of filtering right that we are
filtering as uh you know when you look
at that water bottle and you put it down
somehow you already know the quantum
mechanics of you know how the plastic
molecules are oscillating well it's
completely irrelevant
and that it's not a level that you need
to access information or infer anything
from you're filtering that out somehow
right and whereas when you pour you
still understand that you don't have to
worry about the plastic but you do need
to worry about the water molecules and
the equations of fluid uh fluid
mechanics right which you didn't have to
before so i i wonder if it's um
i keep i i i keep uh liking to think
it's some kind of filtering but maybe
it's not filtering maybe filtering isn't
the right word um
for it
i think yeah i think you you're right
like somehow you need to know what's
what's relevant it's kind of reminds me
of this kind of famous philosophical
problem called the frame problem then
then it has a paper on it it's like how
do you know what's relevant without
actually
having already no you know
right
like how do i know i don't need to use
the low level fluid dynamics before you
know until you know
without actually using it right and so
i don't think we have actually any
competitive answers to this question
and this is why this is why i asked do
you think there's something hardwired i
mean is there some are there forms of
innate knowledge
that we already have of the world
and
you know i look at a lot of these
experiments that cognitive scientists
with you know uh infants do right like
infant cognition
and they do talk about how we probably
have
some hardwired notion of
you know counting like you know so
because if you give a little infant like
three blocks and then you take away one
they go wham because they kind of know
that there's something
has changed right but but you know i
don't know whether they're they're going
why because they actually know that the
number has gone down or some other
attribute right i mean god knows what
you know um
yeah it seems like having you know some
notion of core knowledge is crucial for
learning the kinds of things that humans
learn um at the same time it does seem
that we do have a certain amount of
flexibility so going to the point that
kyle just made like the zoom you know
this conversation we're having but even
down to like the zoom chord right so how
do i use zoom i press a button and
somehow magically you know i get
connected i don't know you know
underneath that there's you know there's
tcp ip there's like electrons whizzing
around i don't need to um reason about
all that to know how to connect a zoom
call but i might right assume stops
stops working right and um
and so i you know i don't think zoom is
kind of hard coded
natively into my brain or you know or
human's brain right but maybe something
more abstract like notions of objects
and notions of
actions are kind of you know
i mean there's a little bit of chicken
and eggs stuff going on here too which
is of course we build these interfaces
to fit the things that we know and
you know also a lot of the examples that
we're giving are places where
the world does seem to organize itself
in this kind of hierarchical way with
kind of night you know
it what's what's a little bit you know
when you get into the particle physics
side of it you know and you see like the
separation of scales
there it has like a very you know
precise mathematical way and one of the
things that's pretty interesting is that
you know within quantum field theory
there's actually like really deep
statements about uh
about why the world does separate itself
out into these scales and and that's
like a
it's not really clear it's not obvious
at all that that you would be able to
make such strong statements
you know but but when you then go into
things that are like you know when you
start talking about like society or you
know some really complex system
it's not really clear that the that
there is any you know concise definition
i mean like a description of the system
i mean maybe we're just not smart enough
to see it but it's also quite possible
that there just
isn't uh some
you know smaller degree of freedom
reduced description um and if you're in
you know you know if we were kind of
like
cognizant or conscious of that skate
like that scale of things maybe we
wouldn't be having this discussion you
know we wouldn't be like presuming
things so that that's actually a useful
concept
to like break things down and i think
i'll just say that to me this is also
important i mentioned in my talk this
kind of no free lunch
uh
statement and i think it's also true
when you look at like what's going on
with like success and deep learning is
that
there's a co-evolution of
the architectures of deep learning and
convolutional neural networks and things
and the kinds of problems that people
were working on which were you know
mainly image-like problems at first
right and then when you go to data that
has a very different character to it
those models may or may not you know
work well right and so
um and and if you really take yourself
into the extreme of like any possible
kind of data set coming in
so that you really allow yourself like
basically totally unstructured
looking data
then you know basically on average
everything is equally good or bad you
know and and there isn't there's no like
magic bullet out there right so like we
so it's
you know so it's important to remember
that uh you know that yeah the the
extent that any of these things that
we're talking about are going to like
work or be useful or anything like that
is is always going to be within the
context of some
domain of application and
which is which is also reassuring
because otherwise it's like it's a it
sounds it is
anyway so i think um
uh it is 5 30 and there is one more
question that i would like you
and that's for kyle from the the ad from
sbi the advent of powerful machine
learning methods
is enabling practitioners to work
directly with high dimensional data and
to reduce the reliance on expert crafted
summary statistics
so does the introduction of quantum
machine learning or similar techniques
or algorithms point to any qualitative
rethinking of the above statement
um
well
i'm trying to think i mean and a very it
seems like you know if quantum machine
learning or something comes to play it
seems like it would only
either it's gonna not be useful or it's
gonna make it more powerful right so if
it's so i think my statement is
basically that previously we didn't
we really relied on expert knowledge to
try to navigate through
this complicated data and structure it
in a way that we could work with kind of
more primitive computational and
statistical methods
and when you pair with machine learning
we can now relieve the pressure on the
expert
and kind of automate some of that
process which is good and i think you
can't completely get rid of domain
knowledge you're still you still rely on
domain knowledge right yeah well i think
that gets into a little bit of a
question of are you just trying to solve
this particular task at hand are you
trying to do the bigger you know the
bigger thing i think you know if you
really just want the task at hand you
know
pretty
surprisingly good at some pretty
automated stuff you know it's just that
if anything
uh goes unexpectedly or like you know
you you you sort of find this like what
do you do next uh if you can't
kind of connect what's going on in this
automated way back to your your your
your domain knowledge then you don't
know what to do and until we get to the
point that we have like much more
powerful ai that knows how to generate
hypotheses and design experiments and
the kinds of things that then was
discussing you know it's important that
humans can touch base with that um for
quantum machine learning in particular i
don't uh
i think you know some of that stuff is a
bit speculative it's you know it's
exciting but i think if that stuff works
out uh well
it seems like it's just going to enhance
the capabilities of machine learning and
maybe
you know so yeah i don't
i don't know that it really changes my
that particular statement but it
certainly will influence the landscape
so um any closing thoughts before we
wrap up
i think it's been really i appreciate
the discussion and i the whole series i
think has been pretty interesting um and
uh thank you for having me
little thank you so much yeah thank you
so much zenna thank you so much kyle for
taking the time and
yeah and this was a wonderful sort of
in-depth uh discussion so i just want to
thank everyone for attending and
look forward to seeing you at our next
event our next event is actually going
to be a book talk by karl zimmer
on his latest book so that's next week
so i will see you all um take care and
bye thanks very much